and joining me on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line right now is the third
leading rusher in the history of the
national football league who's getting
set
to step in the ring and fight in a
boxing match former nba all-star darren
williams in the undercard of the jake
paul tommy fury
bout live on showtime pay-per-view on
september december 18th our friend frank
gore back here on the rich eisen show
how are you frank
i'm doing fine what's up richard
i am doing fine better for talking to
you frank i say this because i care
about you frank
i asked this question because i care
about you what the hell are you doing
frank what are you doing
what are you doing frank what are you
doing nah you know
you know i you know i've been boston you
know i've been trained in boston for
for a while okay you know i fell in love
with it with the sport and um
you know um my man my man monkey um you
know who had connections you know when i
when i didn't get a call going on
training camp
uh i told my i told my boy monkey that
you know i might want to fight
stop being trained in boston and he said
i'm sure and i was like yeah i am you
know and then he started making calls
and then
he got he got he got it done and i saw
him do it all right well i've been at
this uh nfl network only uh nfl only
thing for almost two decades frank and
whenever i speak to a uh a
running back with a hall of fame resume
who's done playing after a very long
time in the nfl the thing they say they
missed the they missed game day they
missed the locker room they missed the
guys the one thing they don't miss is
getting hit and here you are stepping in
a ring do you miss getting hit frank is
that what it is do you miss getting hit
no i don't
i just
you know and
i just kind of got you know um i was
just okay with you know once i started
being around the guys and watching and
and training with the guys in the boston
ring um
it kind of helped me you know trying to
get over football and
you know it's like more like a family
just like football and you know i
just kept getting better and better and
i told my boy um my boy monkey that you
know i want to go and do it you know i
want um see can i get a fight and see
how i do okay you've referred to your
friend a couple times who is this who's
your friend that you've uh you've
referenced a couple times about fighting
um my boy monkey uh first agent
from the first round manage okay on
management um he got a lot of fighters
and in the fight game also in the nfl he
got nfl clients uh he'd been a friend
for me with me for since i was in high
school
and you know
and i just always told him like you know
he's the first one to put me in boston
probably like when i was coming out of
out of college okay going to the league
so i'll
this this the train in boston not not
new i've been training that's probably
2005. okay so so are you saying really
but this this is the first time i'm
really training
for a fight though and it's it's tough
rich man but you know me i'm a hard
worker yes all right learn fast man
i'm ready for the challenge you sure are
frank cory you are
there look there is not a single thing i
don't think you can't be great at if you
put your mind to it that is that is a
fact and anybody who's anybody who's
ever met you and anybody who knows you
and anybody who's definitely played with
you uh they love you man like you you're
universally loved in the nfl community
there's no doubt about that so i guess
does darren williams know what
does does darren williams know what he's
getting into have you spoken him do you
have any connection with him other than
just like getting connected
we kind of spoke over to the ground
um but you know um me i'm you know i
respect darren
you know um i respect what he did in the
nba you know he had a great he had a
great career um right but you know i
can't look past nobody i'm new to what
he knew to it but
you got the the get in the ring you got
to have some type of guts you got to
know that you know something so
um i i'm going to be ready for december
8th um hopefully i know he'll be ready
yeah you know let's go do it have fun
and see best man win so what's your
style
what what's the frank gore boxing style
that maybe folks might it depends what
depends what they track what he tried to
do i'ma adopt whatever he tried to do
and and listen to my coach um i can boss
i could bang
um i can do whatever i say
so
um i've been sparring some some heavy
hitters already yeah so you know i
i know i could take a hit but um
you know i'm i'm happy about it i'm
happy that i you know
still can compete at something you know
um
i was doing for a while and my first
fight december 18 and i'm looking
forward to it okay is anybody that uh
from the nfl world your team your former
teammates calling you up saying oh man
what are they saying they all called me
justice mills tested me
brandon davis my full bet milan mirandas
they call me virginia working
um you know all my boys for the 49ers on
t.y hilton
um he's been calling me to make sure i'm
you know ready for i can be ready and
look good december 18 um
so man i'm just i'm excited about it
i've been working my behind off
and you know we'll see how it goes
december 18. frank gore here on the rich
eisen show uh adrian peterson's back at
it because derek henry got hurt have you
gotten any calls from the nfl this year
saying if you want to keep running i had
three i had three calls man i had three
calls
and uh you know my boys in college you
know and
i just
whenever when that when i started
doubting myself and [ __ ] i would
if i want to do it that's when i was
like you know what i'm just leave it
alone you know because i never doubt it
you know i had doubts in my head if i if
i should play or not so
if i weren't sure i'm gonna get 110
percent i didn't want to do it i didn't
want to go out there
you know and give us the team
not all of me you know so that's why i
didn't do it i had three calls okay i
had um who called i had i had my last
call
right
about a month ago man
uh and you know they asked me if i'm
serious about boston i said yeah i want
to do it
and they just left it all
who called you frank can you tell me
uh i don't want i don't want to put it
on the air okay um
you know you know i just
i leave it alone but i have three calls
for sure i'm not you know we should when
we're together if i see you uh okay
before we can i should i say the test
messages all right that's good i'll i'll
take it at that so so uh when you said
you were doubting yourself what do you
mean because again you're you're getting
hit you're boxing i mean you're training
this is serious work that you're putting
in so that's
that's not the issue so what were you
doubting what were you doubting about
playing i was doubting if i really want
to play ball or not like if i to do it
if i want to stay home if i want to go
like you know you know my boys in
college southern miss you know i haven't
you know only i have i missed a lot of
his time my younger kids time like being
around them and when i when i didn't go
to camp you know i kind of made me see
what i missed with my kids you know and
when i got the call i got a call
probably like a week
like a week after um we got the like a
week before the season
you know a week before this evening um
team called and wanted me to come up
and i was going for my family to
wisconsin to see my stepson play eel
freshman
and i told them i couldn't make it they
wanted us to leave he wanted me to come
on a friday
and i told him i couldn't make it
because man the family had a trip to go
see my stepson go play his first college
game
and they was like what about monday so i
said okay i'll see when i got home
monday
i just told him i didn't want to do it
and i just left it like that
okay
all right frank gore you think you
should be in the pro football hall of
fame frank gore
what do you think i think i think yes
the guys who
who played against me they'll agree that
i should be in there you know i did the
right thing on and off the field
i made plays when i hadn't made plays
for my team a good teammate
i bust my behind you know i did anything
as a running back and do broadcast run
my numbers look good the only thing i
didn't do is just won the super bowl and
you know that's that's hard to do i
played in the super bowl um
you know i felt like we i did good
things that we had a chance to help my
team win it
but we didn't but
you know you have the guys who i
prepared against
yes i should be
you scored a touchdown and 100 yards in
that super bowl that you didn't win
frank so you did you did what you had to
do
if i probably would have scored that
down the four-yard line i probably got
to mep that game
and then we wouldn't even be taught we
wouldn't even be having this
conversation i i bet i mean what does it
mean to you
uh to that that you see on the list and
the names in front of your emmett and
walter and everybody else is behind you
and the person who starts that list is
barry sanders
frank
i've been blessed
blessed man i mean a lot i've been
blessed
you know rich like
the one easy
you know for me to get to the nfl you
know i
blow two of my knees out you know i've
been doubted
you know people wrote me off saying i've
been indeed three four years and
you know i get dropped the third round
you know they told the 49ers i see fans
and they reach for me they could have
took me later than that or undropped it
and
you know i played 16 years man
15 years 16 000 yards five pro bowls
uh everywhere every team i played on i
was like on the main golf team um
you know um i did it on the field off
the field and
you know and
see where i come from and why i finished
that man yeah it's hard and i've been
blessed
you see what the niners did last night
frank you checked out yeah i did i was
happy they got a young kid out there now
man um doing a great job man
on six round picks
elijah mitchell
yeah he's
yeah he had almost 100 yards last night
and he's just stepping in in a role that
he probably didn't think or even dream
that he would have right now and the
niners sitting there at four and five
when you see
this team right now does it does it
resemble
the niners teams that you uh
you kind of either played for or have
been rooting for so far what do you
think i would say that i would say they
got a good team but
man richmond we we're just playing with
we had that run man we were some dogs
man i'm not saying they're not dogs but
you know offense defense
across the board man we know what we was
with physical it was tough
we knew like when y'all we knew like
when teams come to play us they couldn't
they couldn't match our physical it
can't be physical like those so
um
you know i i like i like what they're
doing i i always feel that they got a
chance um out there now because i feel
like they got a great coach
uh kyle he a very great great um play
call he put his players in great
positions and um i and i still think
they got a chance to make
they make a run to try to get in the
playoffs
well frank i don't know darren williams
i have no relationship with him but i
don't know if he's understanding what
he's about to get into
what he's about to tangle with you know
i mean i guess when you're driving the
paint you get knocked on your ass and
he's a you know three-time nba all-star
a couple of olympic gold medals
in his case he knows what tough
competition is but
16 000 yards the national football
league as you just described your
journey that is no joke sir um
i wish you good luck i always loved
talking to you frank or always you you
you the one gave me the nickname baby
you're the inconvenient truth frank that
is you that's what that's what that's
what they that's what i'm coming out to
baby come on now that's what they call
that's what that's what they call my
name that's what i'm walking out to they
could be true baby
so you're saying
my nickname for you
is what you are coming out to ladies and
gentlemen
coming to the ring right now the
inconvenient truth frank gore that is
what you're saying
yup fantastic
i can't wait to see that i did frank
gore i did everybody around here gives
me grief for the number of times i'm
trying to nickname people
i'm the original so are you
i'm thrilled
you have no idea you just made my day
too thanks for the call frank gore i
look forward to seeing you touch gloves
with darren williams on the uh december
18th in tampa florida showtime
pay-per-view let's let's connect after
the fight and beyond
i appreciate it the one and only frank
gore follow him on twitter and instagram
frank gore right here on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here